hello everyone welcome to today
samples and data the two layers of
integrations I'm Judy O'Rourke of
laberd's and I'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's webcast is presented by lab
roots comm the leading social media site
for science professionals and sponsored
by Beckman Coulter life sciences Beckman
culture life sciences develops
manufactures and markets products that's
simple simplify
automate and innovate complex biomedical
testing more than 275,000 Ekman culture
systems operate in both diagnostics and
life sciences laboratories on seven
continents for over 75 years our
products have been making a difference
in people's lives by improving the
productivity of medical professionals
and scientists supplying critical
information for improving patient health
and delivering trusted solutions for
research and discovery to learn more
about Beth Mann Coulter life sciences
please visit www.cancer.gov the
presentation window and typing in your
comments and questions will try to get
to as many as we can and will follow up
if we don't have time today want a
better look you can enlarge the slide
window by clicking on the screen icon in
the lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you can't hear or see this
presentation properly let us know by
clicking on the support button at the
top right or use the Q&A button we'll
make sure we try to resolve any issues
this webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credits please
click on the CD button at the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
receive your credits now let's get right
to today's presenters we are proud to
welcome dr. Russell green project
manager and Kim Sherrill staff systems
engineer both from Beckman Coulter life
sciences Russell green has a degree in
biochemistry and molecular biology and a
PhD in crystallography from the
University of Leeds in the UK he worked
in research for two years at the
University of Leeds
then moved into a role as an automation
specialist before taking on
management duties in the UK in 2010
Russell then moved into the email
marketing team as a field marketing
manager in 2012 he is a 10 year veteran
of automation at Beckman Coulter most
recently Russel returned to project
management by leading the developed
markets team for automation
Tim Sherrill works in the integrated
solutions group he received a degree in
computer science from the rose-hulman
Institute of Technology tim has spent
his career with Beckman Coulter in the
areas of software research and
development custom engineering services
field project management and life
science automation his projects have
focused in the areas of automated data
processing and last year on a new
version of Beckman cultures data
management product Dart
I will now turn the presentation over to
dr. Russell Greene and Tim Cheryl thank
you for the introduction and thank you
for joining today so this is a two-part
presentation and I'm gonna give the
first part of this and just to guide you
through what we're going to be talking
about today are I'm gonna start off by a
very brief run through our and biomech
continuum so our collection of
automation products just to give you
some context as the to the breadth of
solutions that we would try and address
with the kind of options we're talking
about today and then I want to go into
some of the challenges that we face in
cell culture automation in particular we
will later on be focusing on a cell line
development workstation but already
speaking that the challenges that we see
when working with cells and trying to
culture them a very similar regardless
of the scale of automation that we're
talking about I then want to speak to
the software solutions that we have for
controlling those workflows that before
going into that that example cell line
development system and some of the
devices and challenges that are
presented to us as well and then I'll
hand over to Tim who will talk through
how we then would solve the data
problems first setting of workflows and
I hopefully you'll see as we go through
this talk that many of the challenges we
face a really software or data issues
and although once we
once we have the hardware and we may
have all the pieces on there really how
we control them and how we handle that
data is really how we solve a lot of
these particular problems specific to
cell culture so this slide represents
our current portfolio of automation
products and I don't want to spend too
much time just dwelling on these
products but suffice to say that moving
from bottom left to top right we have an
increase in potential productivity and
system capability and you can see
starting at the bottom left we have an
entry-level liquid handler that we call
the biomat 4000 and we pass up through
our our various biomech liquid handlers
including the new biomech high 5 and i7
platforms up to integrated systems and
where we add on devices a little bit
like building blocks to build our
functionality for more complex workflows
now this is worth showing because when
we look at cell culture systems we face
similar challenges regardless of the
spectrum and we also have a broad
portfolio of installed base of in
cellular systems so again I have a
similar chart showing increasing
throughput capabilities on the vertical
axis and then the complexity of the
system or the degree of automation or
walk away time on the other axis and
you'll see it as I present some of these
systems and these are all live systems
that are round with customers right now
you can see everything from nap that's
simple Biomet 4000 benchtop liquid
handler up to the integrated systems and
just just to highlight a couple of these
in particular and that by met 4000 and
we play several of these that really
just do a simple media exchange for
small number of plates on the top left
we have what is essentially a straight
board liquid handler attached to large
capacity incubator in order to do a huge
amount of media exchange so for some
cell line maintenance activities on the
bottom right we have a more complex
liquid handler which you can't see on
this image but has some some
capabilities integrated on deck attached
to a relatively small incubator
now what that system is doing in this
particular
there's 3d cell culture whereas which
has a much more complex workflow and we
already ever running a throughput of
plates in the order of 10 to 20 I then
finally the other one I'd like to
highlight it in the top right at the
high end of a spectrum this is a large
system with both eyes droop and high
complexity which is designed to do and
stay on line maintenance for some 40
cell lines simultaneously over the
course of many months so you can see
that we are a spectrum of systems here
that address a variety of different cell
culture challenges now what I want to
try to on the next couple of slides is
just some of the challenges in
particular I character would open that
cell culture presents to us and how we
solve a couple of them that are actually
common throughout all of these systems
so what does cell culture present to us
as an automation vendor well the first
challenge is that typically this is very
long processes they can be weeks or
months and one immediate challenge for
us is that most software that liquid
handling or automation vendors suppliers
really under designed to cover a run
within a day and so what I mean by that
is within a day I may want to do 40
plates worth of media exchange that
would be a day's worth of activity and
all our software is designed to cope
with that but the questions how do we
then link together those processes that
make that into a full cell culture
workflow from self seeding right through
to some kind of harvesting there's
typically a large amount of lab where in
the system obviously not at the very low
end this is specifically specific to the
medium or high throughput systems where
we it doesn't take a lot of rocket
science to calculate if you go from and
some cultures in the 96 while playing
you want to expand every well up through
24 and 6 small plates and finally into a
one world plate or a flask that you're
having an ever-increasing amount of lag
were in the system over time there's a
lot of data and this is one of the key
things we want to talk about today and
that date it could be sample identify as
it could be the volume information it
might be what type of media do I need to
use it could be and data that we've
gathered on the system such as
we'll come back to this later on and how
that might drive what is what is the hit
for us to carry on through that data I
have just alluded to can drive decisions
I want to passage myself at a certain
compliments and every time every swell
goes at a different rate and so I need
to make a decision about how I handle my
lab where a well based level because
biology doesn't work in a uniform way
very often I have large volumes of media
so liquid handlers and in the market
that we're talking about here tend to
operate in the microliter to milliliter
range whereas the amount of media that
we might need for a process is typically
in the hundreds of meals if not liters
and so we need to have some solutions
that deal with that and of course we
don't want to shock ourselves by and
pouring cold media on top of them so we
need to have some way of delivering nice
warm media onto the deck of the robot
into the cells we also need to handle
liquids in a very careful way and this
is one of the things must be to in a bit
more detail and automation can't do
everything a manual petter can do we
move in a specified set of axis that
doesn't have the same twisting motions
for example the human hands might have
but we can do certain things to emulate
that and I'll come back to that in a
moment
of course adherent and suspensions don't
require very different considerations
you may need to integrate a centrifuge
for suspension cells in order to do a
splitting or packaging exercise and last
but certainly not least systems Cyrilla
t there are a number of ways that we can
approach that and that's not something
I'm going to speak about in it in much
detail today so how do we solve these
problems I have thrown out there is very
consistent problems we face in cell
culture so the first one I want to talk
about is handling delicate cells and
this is about a petting control and
again this is primarily a software issue
so when most liquid handlers out there
we all have the ability to move liquid
up and down but clearly if you want to
be more careful with your petting it's a
software control issue how do I control
the speed of that how do I move around
while stretching to create a particular
motion
so the question is can an automated
liquid handler manipulate cells as well
as a human when the answer is actually
yes often people think no but the answer
is yes but with some particular
considerations and it's very common that
when we automate a process you do have
to tweak some things how do we prepare
cells gently well by ohmic systems can
control their speed a very fine level
and also move whilst per petting and and
this is really key you can imagine if
you just were to go to the central well
and very rapidly dispense media into it
you're probably going to create some
kind of dead patch of cells in the
middle or at least blast those to the
edge of the wells what we would tend to
do is move the pipette around what
petting that medium much more slowly so
that we're not impacting on that on that
adherent layer of cells on the base of a
plate similarly how do we remove media
without disturbing cells well if it's a
small well plate and what I mean by that
is something like a 96-well plate we can
simply move our Cappetta to the side of
the well aspirate and normally the
surface tension is sufficient to
aspirate the liquid we could actually
potentially move our pet chip around the
edge of the well to drag up those last
few droplets if required if we move onto
large a well plate so something like a
six roll plate we would normally need to
then be able to tilt the plate and in
the top right you can now see an image
of our unidirectional tilting position
that would go on the robot that will
automatically tilt the plate a non-law
onto that short axis so the liquid goes
to the edge of the wells allowing us to
aspirate it without going near those
cells going off a level from that a
single well plate or even we would do
this potentially with some of the six
wall plates as well we can tilt in two
dimensions to move liquid to the corner
so this in this particular device is
slightly different allow us to actually
rock the plate in all dimensions and
stop it at a given position so we might
tilt a one well plate on one axis and to
the short axis and go in with eight
competitors to rapidly remove the
majority of the media on there and then
in a second pass we might move it to the
corner to aspirate the remaining liquid
with a single pet chip and before we put
our new media back on top
/ petting control is absolutely critical
to careful cell handling as I said
earlier on this is a software issue and
how we take control of that better
really defines how we're able to
recreate some of those potential issues
you might face in transitioning from our
manual process to an automated one so
I'm going to show you a video in just a
moment and based on these skills that
just just I thought I can't speak whilst
the video is playing so I'm just going
to talk you through it now to say that
this is one example of how we recreate
those complex manual movements you'll
see two videos playing in parallel the
one on the left is actually a manual
manual petting action just showing how
yours wash media over the top of
themselves in a six role play and you'll
see the motions are clearly something we
can't do in an automated fashion on the
right you'll see in us recreating it in
a very similar of a different way where
we can tilt the plate in that same way
and then we can move that the pet to the
right and left as we do those betting
motions so if you play the video now
please
so hopefully that given you a good
example of how we can mimic something
that it may be as thought to be a
difficult thing to transition to
automation I have a second example here
as well I also want to show you which is
also a very simple motion of shaking and
you can see a similar set of videos here
on the Left we have a shaking action
delivered by someone holding a plate
onto a bench and there's just an example
of how we would mimic that an automated
point of view by shaking in a similarly
linear fashion so if you could play the
second video please
so
another example of how we can mimic the
kinds of things that you do manually
unallowable an automated platform to
work with yourselves when we come to
think about shaking we can actually
control the speed of the shaking in a
linear fashion we can also move to doing
an orbital shake and control the things
like the amplitude by doing these and
different shakers and also the speed
that we would we would want to shake out
these are both good examples of some of
the tools that we have at our disposal -
we traced a lot of those manual motions
the one our next area I wanted to speak
about from our - lots of things that we
have - to be able to handle cells is how
do we deliver media this is often
overlooked from with designing systems
or when people are designing automated
systems because the amount of media for
even a relatively low throughput
experiment can be quite fast so just to
to touch on a few of these points
typically media is stored on the deck of
the robot and that could for a Lothrop
activity just be some kind of disposable
reservoir that's very common on a bi mát
4000 type solution when we're looking at
something higher throughput that we
might be running on one of the Bionic
iSeries we typically would want to
deliver media in some kind of refilling
reservoir and the image on the top right
is actually something specifically
designed for the cell culture market
which is an automatic refilling
reservoir that has four segments in it
so it only occupies the same position as
one plate on the robot so you don't lose
a huge amount of debt capacity to this
kind of system but it allows us to
deliver four different media types to
the deck and and keep those media
temperature controlled on deck as well
to go with that we can also do inline
media handling sorry inline media
heating and clearly if we constantly
refilling a reservoir on deck then we
might be delivering if the media
restored chilled below deck a chilled
milled ear into a warm environment and
we don't get a very good consistently in
temperature so we can actually warm that
media as it travels towards that
refilling reservoir just to allow us to
ensure that we're not shocking ourselves
with something that's a different
temperature from what they're expecting
another way uncertainly this isn't you
all of the ways that we might deliver
media but another very common way is to
actually own is to integrate a dispenser
and typically we use devices like the
thermo multi combi or the biotech multi
flow to which we would integrate
directly on the deck of the robot and
these are suitable for delivering one
media type most commonly in a very large
volume and one of the advantage of this
compared to the refilling reservoir
would be that the system is typically
sealed so you see on a bottle on to the
dispenser and then that doesn't get
exposed the environment until it till it
travels out of the nozzles into the
plate so again it's just some examples
of how we deal with some of the media
issues of how do we get media that maybe
needs to be kept warm or chilled below
the pinch of the robot to the system in
the volumes that we require in order to
process the number of plates that
typically pass through these kinds of
systems so while it's not exclusive if
those are some of the things we have in
our toolbox that help us to solve some
of these challenges around handling
cells one of the other main challenge as
I said earlier on is really about
software how do you control these
systems and so I just want to spend a
bit of time talking about that now this
is a block diagram just showing a very
high level
our software hierarchy and going from
bottom to top the purple box represents
our liquid handing software by Mac
software which control rule about
petting parameters within the bobbitt in
the red box have some EDX which is our
planning scheduler which allows us to do
that daily tasks that I talked about
earlier on so if we wanted to process
and 40 play to the media exchange that
is typically a Sami task and then the
bit that I want to focus on is the beat
above now in the orange box which is
something quite unique which is timing
process management which allows us to
link together those daily tasks into a
process that operates over weeks or
months and control all the data and
decisions that go with that and the data
and decision-making facilitation is
really handled by this blue box on the
Left which is our dart software each
team is going to touch in a bit more
detail later on
to show you this in a slightly different
way and this is a very busy slide but if
you'll just walk through this with me at
the very bottom we have a representation
of our liquid handling softer the biomat
software and the kind of tasks that
those would that would facilitate I
wrote that liquid handling level so
removing supernatant and adding media as
an example of the two steps in a media
exchange Sammy would then bring those
components together into that one media
exchange method and allow you to run
that for multiple iterations
Sammy approaches management going the
one level above that allow you to tie
that media exchange method in together
with maybe your pathogen method and
other methods as part of your entire
process and in the background dart is
then handing all the data that goes with
that and allowing you to report on that
so as we said before cell culture
process is present a challenge because
they're long and complex
so speaking of it more these about
process management what that's doing I'm
going to ask some questions here so how
do i how do I connect multiple
automation methods that are dated apart
for example these are all independent
Sammy type methods these are all
independent daily tasks seeding cells
exchanging media and checking comprehend
see each spread apart by a two day
incubation before we maybe then make a
decision about going into some kind of
scale up how do I know it well or sample
based decisions within this process
confluence very often drives the day
that we actually passage those cells how
do I keep track of multiple batches it's
very common that we have a three month
long process you don't want that to be
the only thing your system is doing
there's a lot of spare time in there and
so how do I build in maybe a second or
third iteration of the second or third
batches into that process they're not
ready there some other questions do I
have capacity to even do that in the
system and what is the implication for
my existing run that I have in there and
of course then you have some questions
when you get that level of interleaving
where all my samples and place at any
moment in time and where is all my plate
data
and these are all the kinds of questions
the process management is designed to
solve so standing process management
connects plates through multiple sanding
methods those daily tasks connected into
a process it also then allows you to run
multiple iterations that progress
processes simultaneously and
concurrently Sammy uses this dart
technology the data handling technology
to bring data from previous runs to the
current run so we have continuity of
data and allows you to know where all of
your plates are at any moment in time in
order to keep your system organized the
main user interface that I'll show you
very briefly now is the calendar module
which really shows you your system
resource uses usage and helps you to
plan your tasks as well this is just a
snapshot view of how you would design
your process and if I can just draw on
here these elements are our Sami methods
our daily tasks these parts at the very
beginning is lab we're entering a system
and then you can see they're separated
by those two day incubation so we can
see here very simply how we're building
our process linking together those sani
tasks having built our process you
didn't want to add that into the system
and what would happen is the user would
come in and this is the most common user
activity is to come in and say start a
new process you choose your date in your
time you add in your first step and
there's time your process management add
into the calendar every subsequent step
you would then need to go through a
process of resolving conflicts so it
will tell you whether you are planning
to do something at the weekend or
evening maybe you're happy to do that we
have many of our users that are most
people don't want to come in at the
weekend and would rather avoid that and
so they want to figure out how they
would approach that problem it will also
understand with your and going to reach
an overcapacity of the system we only
have a certain capacity inside the
incubators typically and I think more
and more batches into the system may not
be possible
it also helps you identify overlapping
tasks as well and that may cause you to
want to move a task out to her to a
consecutive day if you do need to do
that in a timely process manageable and
then with also move all the subsequent
dart tasks so you can try and maintain
your process as close to the original
intended use and here we can see a final
snapshot of the calendar module just
showing us several iterations of a
fairly basic eight-day process overlaid
on top of each other
and you can actually just see in the
bottom part of that window if I was to
try and run this this particular process
I do have a number of tasks but I would
need to resolve in terms of overlapping
activities because the way that I've
built this out one final part and
function of sanik process management I
want to touch on is the imprecise
decision-making this is one other
further problem so in a typical cell
expansion method from line six well
place to 24 well plates we only really
want to move those on to the next step
when they reach a certain competency we
would typically using an in process
imaging system to do that which I'll
come to in a moment when we look at the
CLD system but our cells all grow at
different rates so how do we deal with
that and so here you can just see on the
flow chart on the right typically what
happens if the cells come from the
incubator we met at the confluence and
then some wells move into the pathogen
route and some cells do not they get
passed passing into the incubator this
means we now split our plates into
different groups at this stage and
depending on their process stage and
sampling process management can handle
all of this for you it will also help us
to decide at what point we want to ditch
those plates as well so we may decide
that some wells are never going to reach
the confluency to move on and so it also
helps us to eliminate cells the touch we
don't want a passage at this stage
clearly a single iteration of sani won't
be able to handle this and so standing
process management is the tool that we
allowed to grow to make that decision
and handle all of those splitting well
groups up and keep them in process
so moving on to the final part of my
slides I want to talk about the an
example automated cell line development
system so this is actually a live system
we have out in the field there is trying
to develop cell lines that exhibit
distinct antibody production
functionalities in a fully automated
fashion so this is processing a very
large number of cells beyond what we can
handle manually in order to screen for
antibody production functionalities and
scale the ones up that we want to carry
forwards the process that the customer
has here broadly speaking is that they
are going through a seeding process into
an expansion and we are also screening
during that expansion for antibody
production and growth criteria and then
that that can then split out downstream
into cryo conservation or filled out
cultivation before going into other
analytics and actually the basic of
process that we're interested in is
purely this expansion part here the
expansion part operates primarily about
one of these per well decisions but I've
already mentioned based on using a clone
select imager to measure confluence and
we use that conference a drive which
cell has passed through in the process
so the system looks like this and I'm
going to go into a bit more detail at
this and over the next couple of slides
but it's based around a biometric I
seven jewel on liquid hunter and you can
see there are a number of devices that
are integrated around this as we look
from the rear you can see we have a
robotic arm that is integrating us to a
few further devices that maybe weren't
so visible from the front view to speak
about this in a bit more detail looking
at it from the front we have that Bionic
I step in dual arm liquid Honda which is
doing the vast majority of the liquid
handling on this particular system
behind that we have that robotic arm
which is integrating those devices
behind to the right we have an automated
co2 incubator so this is controlled co2
level this is controlled humidity much
like any of your cell incubators that
you would have in your laboratory that
co2 incubator is linked by a plate to
shuttle directly to the deck of the
robot so we don't have to pass you the
robotic arm
and then we also have a dispensing
device integrated on dent which on this
system actually serves two functions if
both seed sells into three or four well
plates in the beginning of the process
and it delivers media to those plates as
we as we move on into 96 or plates also
I want to touch on a bit more detail on
the analytical devices that we have on
this system so and the first one that we
use which was integrate on the right
hand side is a five cell this is a very
cool two device that counts both and
cell numbers and viability and presents
us with a couple of data challenges
around the fact that we gather a single
data point per one which needs to be
mapped back onto a plane to the by cell
cloning process one sample which is
typically coming from a ninety six
twenty four or six well plate and of
course those cell counting data does
Drive betting steps and we recently
released some excellent publications on
on how we can do that very reproducibly
the next analytical device which is of
the rear and is integrated by the SCARA
robot if he is the architect which is
from pooled forte bio and that does
label-free analysis for determination of
affinity kinetics and concentration in
the context of this particular workflow
we really just use it for calculating or
gathering antibody concentration data
which then uses us and there which we
then use to drive hit picking
information for picking high producers
the final device that I want to touch on
is the molecular devices clone so that
imager are also integrated to the to the
rear of the system and we're using this
they can do some other detection but
we're really using this together our
confluence data which then drives at a
well based level where we passage or
split those cells and all of those data
from those devices also needs to be
accumulated and tracked through the
system so that we can understand the
growth profiles and expression profiles
of those different cell lines or
different samples that are passing
through the system to final scan up so
just in summary of my part to talk here
and we do have a wide variety of study
other solutions out there that the
utilize a lot of the same tools
but we've installed base systems for
both sound like development as I've just
shown you so like maintenance for high
numbers of cells that needs to be looked
potentially turned into assay ready
plates monoclonal antibody production
IPSC stimulation screening and cell
culture as well as 3d cell culture we
have some dedicated tools that help us
to solve those particular challenges
around cell manipulation and probably
more importantly we have some software
tools that allow us to manage these
processes within process decision-making
of as part of our package and that's
timing Process Management so this stage
I'd like to hand you over to Tim who's
going to now take you on a bit of a
journey through how we sold data
problems for those cellular workflows
thank you very much Russell that was
excellent and just as a reminder please
be thinking about any questions so will
be some time at the end to take those I
look forward to seeing what comes up
I've been working with automation and
with robotics and scheduling for over 20
years and I can tell you that 20 years
ago that the challenge was really about
moving samples through a system and
sample handling was was a big challenge
but today we would consider that mostly
a salt problem and so today's challenge
where we're the more the cutting edge is
is to make sure that you're managing
your data along with your samples and
that's really the the impetus behind our
talk about having two different layers
of integration both the sample
management and now I'll go into the data
management to repeat Russell slide
you're looking at the continuum of
liquid handling and automation products
that we have I want to start pointing
out where some of the data challenges
come in and the data challenges come
really at every level handling data is
not something that occurs only at the
most complex cell processing systems but
even an individual hit picking in
seeding or feeding operations that are
done even at the entry level automation
systems we still have those data
management challenges again reiterating
the list of challenges that Russell
prepared for you there are a number of
day
challenges that are intermixed with the
sample processing challenges the fact
that we have long processes that run
from weeks to months maintaining an
understanding of the traceability and
the information being processed is
important having large a large number of
plates in the system as layers of data
which just accumulate samples Wells
media types concentrations you want
data-driven decision making and then
handling liquids and driving pipetting
hit picking those are all elements that
come into the data domain so that we're
clear there's a lot of different ways to
look at data what are some things that
that I see so certainly as you bring
information in from a cell from an Excel
spreadsheet or from a limb system but
there's there are types of data this
this is more of informal beta which is
important but can still be become useful
as you're looking back at your results
later now what was my lot number did I
did I write that down that I take good
care of my record-keeping information
that's on a plate or even a Sharpie that
you use to indicate how you're
processing this plate these are all
things that if tracked electronically
add to your data record and the more
information you're able to accumulate
the more you're able to use in your
reports to draw conclusions or heaven
forbid you need to do some root-cause
analysis of failure it can help with
that extent as well so as we look at
data through this talk I want to talk
about some specific process level data
it could be something like the the
identity of the well and the sample ID
that's inside of it could be the
concentration or volume of a well is
this well being used as a as a standard
a control a blank or is it an assay well
if we're doing hit picking is this one
that will continue or well that's left
behind we can log things like the user
the method name did the
finished correctly and then as we learn
things about the system we have
different analytical devices that will
be telling us telling us answer so so
these things on the post-its are more of
my my concept of what data we would be
managing as we move through a system who
is interested in data well in the end
really everyone is whether you're
operating the system whether you're
managing a lab if you're investigating
and trying to learn something if you're
leading a project to make some sort of
discovery if you're purchasing
automation or or reviewing to see
whether results are correct all these
different people are interested in data
and we need to find a way that we can
take use the same information to make
sure that daily operation happens
properly that purchasing knows the
consumables to be buying that the lab
manager is getting the results and that
the researcher can publish and that as
an auditor or maybe a quality check that
anyone who's looking over your shoulder
is also satisfied this is really a
multi-faceted element and so we want to
make sure we capture this data so that
we can serve all of these different
different constituents so as we go
through these next slides I'm going to
talk about four challenges and as we
make a data management plan I want to
really think about kind of three
different elements that that come into
play the way that data is handled is it
it first is imported or introduced into
the system and then it's it either
drives behavior of the system or is
discovered as part of the system such as
in a reader value and then that
information is looked at and some sort
of Bob action is taken some sort of
analysis takes place so those are the
three steps but I'll break it down into
four different challenges and that's
really what we're here to discuss these
four challenges first of all we'll begin
with sample identification this may be
coming from
something that's entered that could be
from barcode reads it could be from from
limbs from a laboratory information
management system we need to then track
the sample IDs through the entire
process samples into assay plates
tracking samples across multiple systems
and after incubations
track them through long-running
processes these are things that Russell
referred to in his part of the talk
today after we've been processing the
system eventually we have some sort of
endpoint we have we have some analysis
that's done so how do we get this
information how do we four bring it in
because data exists in many different
formats on disk these data formats are
changing constantly as new readers are
introduced to the system into our
industry and anything that we learn will
then drive the next steps such as hit
picking or clone selection and then
finally once we've gathered this
information we need to report on it and
then publish that back into whatever
business process is used for the next
step perhaps that would even be part of
a research paper or a poster
presentation so let's break these four
four prop before challenges down and
we'll begin with sample identification
so we're a sample ID come from it may be
imported from a file it could be
something that we retrieve from a web
service or from a lens system in today
I'll show you how to generate new
identity so in cloning you may have
clones that come from the same source so
how do we uniquely identify the
different clones that were then
selecting for further processing one
challenge with CSV files the most common
way to process data between systems
today is that the formatting needs to
match between the output system and the
input to the next step and I just want
to identify that copy and paste is not
an automated solution if you're copying
then you are the robot so let's let's
look at a system and design a data
management approach that makes sure that
these handoffs are done as seamlessly as
possible
so let's take a look at an individual
method this is on a cell culture iSeries
instrument that's in our Indianapolis
lab and I just want to know two
different plates here we'll begin with
clones in a matrix rack and then we'll
transfer those into an assay plate which
sits next to it so if we look at this
method on the left-hand side we have an
instrument setup step and before we do
anything data related we can look at
what data exists on this plate and by
default the biomech and Sammy software
will automatically track the liquid type
and the starting volume that is in the
plate so before you even begin you have
data on on your plate in the system
whether you whether you know it or not
the next thing we'll do is we'll take
the barcode of that plate and the well
number and we're going to create a new
data set and this the this data layer
will be a sample ID this will be the
ancestry of every pipetting operation
that that will follow so in this case
we'll have the the barcode and the well
number that moves on so if we now look
we have created a new data set it's
called clone source and it has the
barcode and the well number that all of
this began there are other ways of
bringing information in dart also has an
import tool which has a way of dealing
with flexibly dealing with comma
separated value input files or importing
from a database and this is another way
to bring information into the system so
this this is how we'll look at sample
identification the next step is that
once you have sample IDs established in
the system if you're bringing this on to
a liquid handler you're going to be
doing pipetting and so in that case we
need to have sample traceability and
this traceability it will be watching
how we move through the system and why
is this important this is important for
three layers one is it helps you
organize your work it's helpful to your
team for internal processes and it's
helpful to others as you look for
submission so why do you why would you
do tracing the question really is why
wouldn't why wouldn't you want to trace
your pipetting to know where each well
in destination plates came from and
while many people will do traceability
as needed isn't their value in always
doing this what what if you could get
traceability for free well that's
something that we can look at with the
biomech software you can have many
different data sets associated with each
well in both the biomech and Sammy
software and then in this well we can
have different types of data which can
all coexist and then all of it gets
tracked when transfers are performed
whether in biomech ER and Sammy software
so in this case we have a very simple
animation where the pipette tip will
aspirate from a source well move and
then dispensed into a destination well
the advantage of working with the
Beckman software is that as you aspirate
sample you also aspirate data and then
can deposit it into the destination
while so without doing any sort of
specific data management tasks that
pipette tip is your data movement tool
and so different data sets will move
along to the destination let's pick up
this assay what we've done is we're now
looking at the assay plate and we've
transferred one column of information
from the matrix rack into column one of
the destination plate you can see the
sample IDs have been picked up when we
perform a serial dilution we're diluting
across the first six columns the first
the left half of the plate if you will
and those sample IDs are copied through
all of that as well so later when you're
looking at your your your curve you can
see the origin of each of those samples
that's in the plate and you get all of
this for free as the sample and data are
pipetted together
so now let's turn the corner just a
little bit to start to look at how we
bring information into the system in the
end you're going to target some sort of
plate reader in order to bring
information in our software all hinges
through our stylist technology in the
Blue Square and so as we look at the
different layers this is again repeated
from from Russells talk where we have
different different pieces of software
that come into play depending on the
complexity of the system and and the
length of the workflow but we will use
these different pieces together in order
to get our results so why are we running
these assays because we need to get some
sort of outcome and this outcome is
important for making decisions such as
in hit picking and one example of that
would be promoting clones for further
processing and we also need this
information in reports for downstream
processing as we add new devices to a
system that the modality that we use
today is not the same the same reader
that we were using five years ago the
technology when it comes to cell culture
data gathering changes year to year and
so we need to have some way of adding
new devices to the system likewise
there's no one endpoint reader which
gives us all the results that we need
and we'll look here in a minute as to
how we can do hit picking on multiple
different inputs as we combine the
information from three different readers
we want to be able to use this
information for in process
decision-making if we need to stop the
process so that a user that that a human
is doing an analysis of this of course
there are times when that's the only way
that this can happen but one goal in the
data management plan would be to
automate the sample evaluation so that
we can connect to different processes
and Umbridge those with automation so if
we again look at the Silas bubble here
we see that is connected to a robot to a
reader to a washer and this is a way
that we can swap out different devices
within Beckman automation here are three
different different data producing
devices in the top right hand side we
have the Beckman Coulter vice al
followed below it with the Paul octet
and the silver device is the molecular
devices clone select and the lower left
is the molecular devices I three
spectrum acts I three with the minimax
site ometer the VY cell produces cell
viability and cell count the octet
produces an antibody concentration the
clone select produces confluence and
then rather than using multiple devices
the i3 can do multiple multiple tasks
but may take longer in order to make
that happen
so if we were to take these different
devices and whether they're all
integrated or we're using the data
produced as you carry a plate by hand we
would like to do a hit pick which uses
the following scenario let's pick a
monoclonal seed where the cells are
growing well and are producing the
target protein this is really the the
trifecta that we're looking at for per
cell characterization and for cloning so
we can create a new data set which uses
those three items as inputs and then
creates a true or false to know whether
we'll do further processing what tools
would we use to do that well in the
biomech software you can use the
calculate data set we can use one data
set in the transfer step or a script
node and then in sámi we can use a
script module a third way we can do this
is using our dart data management
software we can create a report that has
the well identifier the three columns
which each have one of the values from
above and then use a formula in Excel to
look look at a comparison that turns
into a true or false value depending on
whether that condition is met and that
information can then be pushed back into
the dart database the final challenge in
dealing with cell culture data is sample
reporting
and getting your result into your
business processing system so we need
something that will log all of our
activities follow traceability through
the system and then review these results
and push them into whatever business
analysis process that we are using dart
reporting can do this through three
different three different layers two of
them are in Excel
one would be an Excel plate map or a
tabular report we can also create
Microsoft sequel server views and that
would be a direct Limbs access and we
wouldn't need any copy-paste through
that you can also use the web for for
direct drill down we can take a look at
that here's the data acquisition
reporting tool it has three pieces to it
it stores all of the data works with
biomech and Sammy and gives that view
remotely the key thing that dart does is
that it will automatically collect this
information and stored and biomech our
Sammy and it's able to retrieve this
information such as after an incubation
when that plate is returned to the
biomech we'll be able to react to it
based upon the information such as the
traceability as well as the data that's
been added through a reader and then in
the end art is the tool that gives us
the best capability to produce reports
one example of what this report might
look like is to show the the method name
the start-finish time the plate barcode
the name and and the incubation times
and then information about the sample
identity some processing information
shown in green and then some analytical
information in this case we have two
different values taken at three
different times resulting in six
different reader values but because we
have all of this information in the same
report we can correlate our or identity
information with the analytical
information and those are conveniently
located side by side using the dart
query builder we're able to keep a live
link from our report back to the system
and refreshing this information allows
us to get new
new information from new runs and
without generating a new report we can
simply update that report with
additional information or we can view it
in the web using our data browser where
we can view run lab where and well data
and perform that drill down so to wrap
up we see that a data management plan
needs to focus on the three components
the three activities that happen in data
processing data import having data drive
decisions within your automation
collecting your data and reporting on it
and if we follow our data management
plan we'll see that certain
characteristics come out a good an assay
with a good data management management
plan will identify compounds and samples
with with identified entity if data will
drive experiment behavior data will flow
through the system automatically without
needing additional steps to process it
will gather information that's learned
such as from a plate reader during the
process it will correlate your identity
your traceability and your analytical
information and then preserve all of
that information so that you can report
on it and drill down process that into
the next system so hopefully today
you've learned something about designing
a system and some of the components that
go into the hard side and into the
capabilities required for pipetting and
managing settles but also how to make a
data management plan so that in the end
your system can process two layers of
samples you have integration both in the
hardware and in data management
well now pause and take questions
excellent presentations rustling Tim
thanks for bringing that information to
us so before we get started with all of
your questions here's a quick reminder
about how to reach us today questions
can be sent via the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window get to as many as we can and our
first
if you're scheduling software compatible
with other liquid handling systems hi
this is Russell I'll take that one and
so if you mean by liquid handling
systems a dispenser or some kind of
washer or wash a dispenser then then yes
has an integrated device we can do that
but in terms of being integratable with
other people's call Petters that then
it's not so our scheduling software or
last time approaches management software
is specific to better and cultural
automation platforms this automation
increase the chance of cell sharing or
aggregation or have you minimize the
risk of cell sharing or aggregation so
coming back to what I was talking about
earlier on with pipette in control this
really is a case of we can mimic what
you would do manually with the fine
control that we have on the biomech to
achieve the same levels of shearing or
aggregation that you might see from that
point of view so so know in a simple
answer automation doesn't increase the
likelihood of that because the fine
control that we have as well as we can
utilize certain things like wide wor
tips to minimize the impact of cells
passing up through the aperture as well
as that find a pet in control
I currently cultured ki 75 flasks can I
use this on one of your systems and if
not then what are the alternatives yeah
that's a good question and it's often
one of the things that we have to think
about most carefully when we move over
to automation is that the lab whether
you use or manually is probably not the
same as that our way you would use an
automated platform so T's only if I
flask is not what we call a standard
footprint lab where for an automated
system and so the kind of lab where we
would use would be multi-well plates as
the largest of which would be actually a
what we call a single well plate or an
omni tray of a particular brand name for
one or there are also automated flasks
as well that have a surface area there
is a bit small
those ones you use manually and so you
tend to use multiples of them but at the
lower end in a spectrum you'd be the
helix well 24 well or 48 well minus 6 or
3/8 for world plates most commonly can
you describe how automating my data
would reduce the copy and paste work in
the lab yes sure this is Tim I'll take
that the one of the more common pain
points as I talk to users they tend to
tend to have two things one is is
mistakes or gaps in data and the other
is having to manually process this
information instead the way we try to
design systems is to look at automated
ways of retrieving information let's say
from a web service or a limb system we
can pull that information in attach it
to a plate and then with the traceable
pipetting that we have you will end up
with those sample IDs right next you
know in parallel data arrays next to the
analytical data and in the end what that
really means is that you can have your
sample ID next to your data very simply
even on long-running processes and then
on the reporting side we can push
information into a limb system or allow
the limb system to pull information from
our system either way and again not only
does it automate that task and remove
the manual step but it reduces the
likelihood of a mistake some sort of
transposition picking the wrong file
really we increase the reliability of
the data workflows but it is a little
bit more work to set up in the beginning
but then you pay off every time that you
run the system and you integrate other
plate readers like an imaging reader
into a workflow yeah certainly we even
integrated a number of different imaging
readers one one note I didn't include
imaging readers in my slides the images
themselves would not be something that
we would attach to our plates as data
directly perhaps
would refer to those images per my file
name or by reference but the scores that
can be generated from those reads can be
attached as data that can then be used
for driving decision-making and used in
the analytical results an automation be
used to optimize culture growth
conditions of bacterial expression
systems ie a coli for time-sensitive
parameters such as OD yeah cool so I
mean that bacterial cultures present a
slightly different set of challenges for
us and they grow much faster so but as
compared to mammalian systems but
automation can still help to process the
samples faster and more consistently and
as we just alluded to we can integrate
other analytical devices and typically
you had used some kind of plate reader
monitoring optical density through
absorbance to characterize the growth of
a bacterial cell culture and we have
customers out there using biomech
systems to do this kind of thing already
such as a selection of successively
modified genes in CRISPR cast line
protocols ok we have time for one last
question so if we didn't get to yours we
will follow up with you via email is
there a way you could help me to work
with my limbs IT folks seems like
they're always busy yeah boy everybody's
always busy and and the thing that's the
reality of today's laboratory is that
information is really a key part of it
so hopefully everyone does have a good
relationship with their IT folks one
thing we've heard about our dart data
manager is that this is a repository of
information that can be under your own
control you can have information on your
system and processing your samples and
you can ask your own questions to get
some quick results now this isn't
intended to replace any
business important decision-making tools
the import and export to a Lim system
for instance should still happen but if
you just want to check on your controls
or build some some simple reports maybe
something you can send to your boss that
gives some summary information that's
all very easily done and so I find that
we still work with IT and
bioinformaticians when we're importing
and exporting data but then using like
the dart webview to look at controls to
look at you know am I getting results
out of my reader do those results look
decent are they at least registering
these are the types of things you can do
and inspect while the system is running
and you can have access to that very
easily people find the web browser you
don't have to go back into the lab you
can do it from your desk and that access
has been very convenient I would like to
once again thank Russell Greene and Ken
Cheryl for their presentations if you
have any final comments know that was a
pleasure to speak today I hope that was
all very informative for you and if you
have any further questions and of course
then you can make contact with us
through the through usual channels
[Music]
I just appreciate I'm pretty passionate
about making sure that we look at
managing the two flows of through the
lab of the data as well as the samples
and I think if everyone keeps make some
sort of thought with regards to a data
management plan that will pay off in the
long run and you will thank yourself in
the future well I would also like to
thank our sponsor Beckman Coulter life
sciences for making it possible to bring
this presentation to you this webinar
has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
CD button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credits
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May 2018
you'll receive an email from us alerting
you when it's available on demand and
posted on lab routes comm you're welcome
to Ford this announcement to any
colleagues who weren't able to join in
today thanks for logging on and
participating in today's broadcast we
will see you next time